[Music]
who's blowing up your phone
oh uh my mom yeah call her when i get
home you're not giving her any
grandbabies say the word i'll set you up
i got cousins
i've met your cousins they're lovely
maybe after i make cheap
hey scotty this is hooch there's food
elise some toys this one's his favorite
mr horsey what are you talking about did
mom call you
your father wanted you to have hooch he
rescued him from the shelter he said it
was
almost like the original hooch came back
i can't
take care of him i'm working all the
time and i'm just still trying to prove
myself here mom
come on you're gonna love him
you're gonna be fine laura i'm late for
work god we've got an emergency here
three males driving a silver suburban
wait silver suburban i see it
pursued
how did this happen also why is there a
dog in the office
uh it's it's a long story short
everybody needs somebody sometimes
traveled this is totally out of control
i don't know what to do i think i might
know someone you can talk to
erica i need scott hi um i'll
let you two chat if there's anything you
can do
i'm desperate he's just totally
untrained pooch sir
down good wow he behaves for everyone
but me
dad wrote it before he passed dear
scotty i know you think you don't want a
dog
but everything i care about in my life
started with a dog
i think we'd see something that we don't
didn't see that coming great job get the
dog out of here
no that dog remains a disaster waiting
to happen he's just drinking the water
for contaminants
we are totally focused on hoots's
training he's getting better every day
[Music]
i am so sorry is he yours oh yeah
unfortunately
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
bye